[Applaudissements]
boussemart à 1050 aujourd'hui l'humanité
atteint le cerisier carbone je vais
profiter de cette date historique pour
raconter comment tous ensemble on y
arriver comment on a réussi en une
centaine laver à unir nos forces pour
résoudre l'un des plus grands défis
auxquels l'humanité était confronté je
vais vous raconter cette histoire qui a
commencé dans les années 1960 lorsque
les premiers scientifiques sont allés
fort et en antarctique et se sont rendu
compte qu'on avait un problème avec le
club je vais vous montrer les trois
grandes étapes qu'ils nous ont permis de
prendre un tournant décisif c'est trois
grandes étapes
elles ont été essentiels pour lutter
contre ce dérèglement climatique et même
aujourd'hui ici en 2050 même si on a eu
des catastrophes
même si on a eu des échecs on peut
vraiment dire que ce dérèglement
climatique a été une formidable
opportunité pour nous rassembler et nous
permettre d'agir pour un monde plus
durable et plus
la première de ces trois étapes
c'est l'impulsion au niveau global cette
impulsion
elle a commencé avec ça ça c'est un
verre de whisky en 1965
claude lorius quand il est faire en
hivernage en terre adélie s'est rendu
compte en mettant des vêtements son
biscuit que les petites bulles que
c'était sont libérés et ai été témoin
fiable et unique de la composition de
l'air lorsque la glace s'était formé ces
saisies plus là qu'ils ont permis
ensuite de reconstruire
l'ensemble sur les centaines de milliers
d'années le climat passé là on voit sur
les 2000 dernières années qu'on a eu un
petit réchauffement climatique médiéval
un petit âge glaciaire et ensuite à un
réchauffement climatique très important
depuis la l'industrialisation et avec
ses petites bulles de piéger dans la
casse on peut remonter dans les huit
cent mille dernières années
votre alter et on voit qu'on a eu des
températures plus importante que celle
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
mais ce qui marque vraiment le
réchauffement qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il a été il est il est 100 fois
plus rapides que tous les riches ou
pauvres on a connu par le passé et est
dû aux activités de l'homme pour faire
face à ce problème
la communauté internationale a fait ce
qu'elle sait faire de mieux
elle a créé des acronymes elle crée
d'avoir le giec
en 1988 le cheix un groupe scientifique
qui fait l'état de l'art et la
connaissance scientifique sur les sujets
de primes
ils ont ensuite créé des rapports qui
était d'aller en année toujours plus
alarme et qu'ils allaient si on fait
rien on va droit dans le mur
la communauté internationale s'est dit
pas il faut qu'on trouve des solutions
ils ont créé les coop alors pour essayer
de trouver des solutions entre tous les
étapes et moi à l'époque je voulais
m'investir sur ces thématiques du
dérèglement 26 et je me suis dis que
c'est vraiment au niveau global qu'on
allait y arriver et c'est pour ça que je
me suis investi dans l'équipe comme un
terme on a eu un succès incroyable avec
la cap 21
parce que contrairement aux présidents
de clubs on a mis autour de la table
tous les acteurs pas uniquement les
couleurs de moore
on a mis la société civile ont nommé les
entreprises on a mis tous les citoyens
qui voulaient participer et ce qui nous
a permis d'aboutir à cet accord de paris
là on s'est dit à ce moment là on est
sauvé on a réussi à résoudre le problème
du dérèglement climatique au niveau
global
on a trouvé un accord entre tous les
étapes c'est génial maintenant c'est
derrière nous et on peut avancer et ça
c'était sans compter les échecs et comme
she vente et l'arrivée a réduit les
grandes nations du monde
l'un des présidents les plus
climato-sceptiques et on s'est dit
qu'ils avaient vraiment problème quand
magie d'édition de donald trump
je rappelle c'était lors de la deuxième
semaine des négociations à la clope 22e
et il y avait une ambiance très
particulière où on avait des
négociateurs qui était complètement
désemparé qu'ils aimeraient tout ce
qu'on a fait depuis le 21 ans ça a servi
à ça
servi presque à rien et finalement il
faut recommencer de zéro et alors on
s'est dit qu'il regardait problème avec
ce niveau global pour agir contre les
dérèglements climatiques
en parallèle de ça on a vu la deuxième
grande étape qui ce qui s'est passé ce
sont les catastrophes naturelles qui
sont multipliés rien qu'en 2019
on avait plus de 1100 catastrophes
naturelles ça ça comporte des incendies
des canicules les inondations les
cyclones et ses catastrophes naturelles
elles arrivèrent encore plus vite que ce
que le giec nous avait prédit et elle
touchait toutes les parties du monde
on se rappelle en 2020 des incendies
énorme pour toucher australie vous sans
même les personnes et les plus climato
sceptiques à dire qu'on avait un vrai
problème avec les dérèglements
climatiques
en parallèle de ça on avait des
scientifiques des milieux scientifiques
qui publiait des tribunes pour nous dire
si on continue comme ça on va droit dans
le mur c'est la catastrophe
il faut absolument qu'on passe quelque
chose et ça dans les années 2020
ça a conduit à deux types de discours le
premier ses discours des
climato-sceptiques tu lisais vraiment
finalement n'a pas de preuves de
dérèglement climatique
ensuite ils ont dit maintenant on n'a
pas de prendre une vraie critique ce
n'est pas dû aux activités de l'homme
on a eu un look aussi un autre type de
discours assez négatif le discours des
clubs sologne environ voilà c'est la fin
du monde
il faut absolument qu'on reste quelque
chose on va construire un bunker de s'y
réfugier et on va attendre que vraiment
sous mon fils et ça c'était vraiment
très intense dans les années 2020 et on
a vu ensuite arriver la troisième étape
celle qui a vraiment marqué un tournant
dans la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique
cette troisième étape elle propose une
alternative aux deux discours négatifs
des climato-sceptiques et des collègues
seul c'est l'action au niveau local on a
vu alors quand les allées de milram
émerger des récits positif qui parlait
plutôt des solutions que les problèmes
en poussant les femmes et les hommes à
agir au niveau local et à voir les
effets de leurs actions
on arrêter d'attendre un messie une
personne qui elle nous sauver un super
héros qu'elle vous sauvez au niveau
global et nous dire préfère on a aussi
arrêté les discours du
ifs moi je veux pas qu'il y ait quelque
chose tombait shiuan pour m ou alors moi
je vois pas pourquoi dans la maison je
vais les fameux mille lumières pourquoi
j'irai au travail en vélo
alors que tous mes collègues de son cas
et ça c'est vraiment très intéressante
que ces solutions on a vu qu'elles se
développer autant dans les pays du nord
que dans l'été du sud et elle se
développer principalement dans les zones
qui étaient le plus touché par les
effets du dérèglement climatique
c'est par exemple le cas des alpes avec
un anglais des alpes la mer de glace
là on voit la mer de glace dans les
années 1900 ça c'est la mer de glace
dans les années de livres mais les
disparitions presque complète de cette
mer de glace et pour aller à la
rencontre des personnes qui trouvaient
des solutions dans les actes j'avais
décidé d'y aller en faisant une
traversée des alpes en marchant et en
venant en appoint pour ceux qui
connaissent pas le parapente c'est un
formidable moyen de se déplacer le faire
des rencontres à ce qu'on sait où on
décolle de matam on sait jamais où on va
atterrir le soir et on rencontre des
personnes qui au niveau local trouve des
solutions incroyable et pour raconter
tout ce bouillonnement qui existait au
niveau local j'ai décidé à l'époque de
créer une collection de documentaires
cette collection de documentaires il
faut sauver l v on a créé avec une
équipe de professionnels de la
télévision et des récits pour vraiment
montré des récits optimiste positive qui
pourra se fait par rapport aux grands
documentaires catastrophiste qu'on avait
à l'époque ça vraiment pour but que des
dizaines de millions de téléspectateurs
une fois avoir vu les épisodes se lève
et envie de passer à l'action au niveau
local dans le premier épisode il faut
sauver les alpes on a vu beaucoup de
solutions au niveau local c'est simple
qui étaient prises par des personnes a
forcément pour réduire leurs émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mais pour avoir
des effets bénéfiques donc un autre
domaine où ces domaines ça fait être
réchauffé humaines l'amélioration de
leur pouvoir d'achat
ou bien recréer du lien social en des
sociétés on était de plus en plus isolé
on a par exemple un la remorque et
producteur ou d'un quatre producteurs
locaux qui sont associées pour qu'à
chaque foyer qu'une personne qui a
offert les marchés ça ça permet
d'économiser mille heures de travail art
pour chaque producteur d' éviter
d'émettre trois tonnes de co2 par an et
en plus ça leur fait un bien de vente on
allait aussi une autre solution leur
hyper café c'est un collectif de
citoyens qui dans la vallée verte s'est
formé pour réparer des objets plutôt que
de les jeter en réparant les objets
électroménagers on a un lien direct
pouvoirdachat on achète à vue à des neuf
et on évite aussi de rejeter beaucoup de
polluants atmosphériques dues à
l'incinération et pour aller plus loin
de cette collection documentaire on a
décidé de créer avec notre équipe
une interface cette interface est le
carrefour des solutions pour accélérer
la transition écologique au niveau local
dans cette interface
il ya deux piliers le premier pilier
c'est les recettes c'est comme dans huit
ans quand vous vous devez faire bruni
chez vous devrez prendre assez sûr
marmiton et balla si vous voulez faire
une station d'épuration personnel si
vous voulez faire un rippeur café ou une
revente de producteurs si vous êtes un
producteur local
vous allez allez sur cette interface et
vous avez de façon très simple pouvoir
répliquer ces solutions
le deuxième pilier de cette interface
c'est une fabrique à solution en allant
sur le terrain il s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait beaucoup de points de
blocage qui existait par exemple un
restaurateur qui a vu sa consommation de
viande rouge augmenté de 200% en un mot
c'est pas de langage ou la vérité sur
cette fabrique et on a créé tout un
réseau d'experts un réseau de
compétences pour trouver des solutions à
ces points de blocage
par exemple pour le restaurateur il y a
des airs une école d'ingénieurs qui a
créé une application pour donner un code
couleur ou poids carbone de ses venues
et donc on a vu à l'époque des millions
de personnes rejoindre ce mouvement ces
récits positif pour s'impliquer sur ces
thématiques et on avait enfin compris
que en agissant au niveau local on avait
un pouvoir fort et direct au niveau
global
cette transition au niveau local c'est
vraiment comme une roue crantée de la
pression écologique c'est-à-dire que dès
qu'on fait un progrès aucun retour en
arrière les possibles et ça c'est assez
intéressant parce que alès ces
comportements ce qui guide et nos
comportements
c'est quelque chose qui est ancré dans
notre cerveau c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'homme se serait à tom il va sécréter
de la dopamine nous récompenser dans les
actions pour assurer la survie de notre
espèce
il assure la survie de notre espèce en
maintenant cinq objectifs
c'est simple objectif c'est le besoin en
nourriture
le sexe le besoin d'information la
reconnaissance sociale et la paresse et
ça le marketing et au xxème siècle ne
l'avait bien compris comment
fonctionnait à notre serveur et c'est
pour ça qu'on a vu plein de pubs comme
ça apparaisse et plus bas les milliards
d'euros investis dans ses publicités là
en nous faisant croire que c'est en
ayant un gros 4 4 qu'on allait pouvoir
avoir plus de reconnaissance sociale et
qu'on allait avoir plus de conquêtes et
c'est pour ça qu'à l'époque on disait
qu'il fallait on est plus on est mieux
de son voisin qu'on avait les 6es ont
été les fon portable très cher ou adele
et dernière paire de chaussures et là on
s'est dit avant 2020 que je vais plus on
pouvait démontrer comme ça et c'est pour
ça qu'il ya eu plein de mouvements qui
étaient destinés à changer le
fonctionnement de nostre à table on a
par exemple le flic scam la route de
prendre l'avion qui est apparue en suède
en disant que non c'est pas les
personnes qui vont aller prendre l'avion
pour aller passer leurs vacances à
l'autre bout du monde que c'est comme ça
qu'on va sécréter de la dopamine acte de
ce riz et fameux et pour sécréter 7
dopamine
on a vu des changements qu'on perd est
très important on en sécrétée par
exemple quand ont participé aux marches
pour le film canton s'associa avec des
collectifs de citoyens pour réfléchir
aux problèmes que nos sociétés étaient
confrontés pour aussi participé à des
jardins partagés ou créer de
l'électricité renouvelable avec des
politiques citoyens et c'est vraiment
une chance monde qui a été majeur à lui
de plus en plus de personnes s'investir
dans la vie personnelle et une fois
qu'elles se soient investis dans leur
vie personnelle
elles ont voulu aller encore plus loin
elles ont voulu transformer leur
entreprise dans institutions leur école
leur région leur miss habilités de
l'intérieur en proposant des solutions
et en étant présent force de le proposer
on est même des dirigeants même et
décideurs politiques n'étaient pas
encore convaincus on a un problème
acquis dérèglement climatique ils ont
été forcés de rejoindre le mouvement et
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce jour du
12 mars 2050
on peut être très fière tout ce qu'on a
appelé toute l'énergie et toute la
motivation qu'on a dépensé au niveau
local pour accélérer cette transition
tous ensemble je pense aux dragons qu'on
peut se dire un grand merci et un grand
bravo les enfants
[Applaudissements]